please be aware there will be occasional
dips in audio quality
i don't know what caused this and i do
apologize for it
yes yes yes infinite possibilities blah
blah blah blah
what is really going to happen from here
on out
[Music]
all right this is your big spoiler
warning i am talking about the
ending of the last episode of loki
and the implications that that is going
to have going forward for the marvel
cinematic universe
so there's going to be spoilers for what
has happened and if i'm right about any
my speculation about how this does
or doesn't play out there's potential
spoilers for future stuff that is your
warning we are getting into this
so after much teasing
in various ways i would say going back
to spider-man far from home
we now have confirmation of a multiverse
for marvel and the restraints that were
implied to be in place
to keep that multiverse from being
infinitesimal those restraints implied
by the
episodes of loki up until the finale are
now off
so it's multiverse time folks everybody
excited
because i'm nervous i'm nervous as heck
i've never liked the idea of the mcu
doing the multiverse for a couple of
reasons first of all if i can be
completely honest
i feel like fundamentally multiverses
are a bit more of a dc thing than a
marvel thing
marvel has a multiverse but
it's one that they just kind of dabble
in every now and then
the only time it really ever had
significant meaning at all was the
ultimate universe
which eventually they just kind of
collapsed that whole thing
dc had a whole long-running thing i mean
it was the entire reason they had their
crisis on infinite earth's
massive crossover reboot thing was to
try and simplify the multiverse and then
eventually realizing
people missed the multiverse i'm
bringing it back and all this other
stuff it feels much more ingrained to dc
than marvel
so that's the first thing i don't feel
like it's a massive part of
at least what i love about marvel that's
the first reason
that i'm not super excited the other one
is i actually always kind of dread
when a creative endeavor has the reigns
almost completely taken off
i honestly think that some of the best
and most
creative decisions get made
under restraint within confines
you can't do anything but given these
limitations
what will you do with it now not all
creative people are going to be like
this but i am personally of the opinion
that
with a lot of creative folks you tell
them they can do anything
they either aren't going to take
advantage of that really
at all and so what was the point of
giving them that much freedom or
they are going to go so nuts with it
that it just kind of makes everything
feel weird and like well it's just not
the same anymore because we don't have
the parameters we used to have
what even is this now will that happen
with the mcu
i hope not i'm not going to say for
certain that it is
but a fear of that has always made me
trepidatious about
a multiverse from the get-go from when
it was first suggested
with those initial trailers for
spider-man far from home the snap to our
hole in our dimension
you're saying there's a multiverse
totally ridiculous and apparently
exactly the kind of thing people will
believe right now
but we've got it now so
how does the confirmation of the
existence of a multiverse
actually play out going forward well
we know a little bit about at least well
two definite probably three films that
it is going to very directly
impact now i actually delayed
doing this video i had considered
cramming this in earlier but i wanted to
wait to see if they would drop a trailer
for
the next spider-man uh spider-man no way
home
watch my luck they'll drop it between
when i shoot this and when it goes up
two days later
wouldn't that be great but assuming that
that doesn't happen
it was rumored that they were holding
off that trailer until loki was done
because it was somehow gonna
uh tie into things even if that doesn't
end up specifically being the truth
uh there's still a lot of rumors around
that movie but i'm getting ahead of
myself let's get to the ones where we
know
multiverse will matter first
up doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
i mean it's right there in the name so
like we knew the multiverse was coming
but here's the thing up until the end of
loki we didn't really know
what that multiverse was going to be
because the term multiverse could
theoretically mean any number of things
because ant-man had
already brought about the idea of say
the quantum realm
which is arguably a completely different
microscopic
universe and we'd seen other dimensions
of existence
in the previous doctor strange with
things like dormammu's realm
so we had had these instances of okay
that's definitely not our plane of
reality
but it's not this multiverse in the
sense of alternate versions of the same
event same reality same people so
up until loki we didn't know if that
kind of multiverse was ever going to be
in play because
honestly doctor strange as a character
in the comics just
passes through and interacts with so
many different planes of reality
you know not even getting into alternate
timelines branching things you know
alternate outcomes and different
universes with this
with the same people in them that it
wouldn't have actually been necessary it
could still have been a multiverse story
now
it seems very likely that this is in
fact going to be that kind of multiverse
story
i will be curious to see how much it
actually depends on what we learned
from the end of loki in terms of kang
having been
someone who is basically keeping the
multiverse restrained and then that
version of kang now being killed and
things
going nuts will that be a direct you
know
the dominoes fall results in what is
going on in multiverse of madness
it's hard to say i'm actually kind of
inclined to say it might be implied that
that's the case
i'd be surprised if it gets confirmed
partially just because of marvel's
still at this point sustained habit of
not
making the shows required viewing to
understand the movies
um you it will certainly flesh out your
understanding of what's in the movies in
some cases but
it doesn't require that you do it
because they've been smart to never
do that i don't think they're gonna
start now and the other reason is they
got sam raimi on board to direct this
and sam raimi he's a
guy who has walked away from projects
before because he felt like he
wasn't he didn't have the control to
make the kind of movie he wanted
and if he felt completely restrained by
existing narratives or
that he was coming to tell somebody
else's story or make a movie that he was
basically just a name being slapped on
and he had to conform to all these
restraints i don't think he'd be doing
it
so given that pedigree and also like
sam raimi directing a marvel cinematic
universe movie yes
please thank you um but given those
things
um i would be surprised as to how much
it's actually going to factor on we know
wanda is going to be there
which brings in one of the things that i
will be touching on later in terms of
where wanda was at the very end of one
division
but we don't know all the details but we
do know obviously doctor strange is
going to be dealing with
the multiverse whether it is going to be
something that he is trying to
re-establish control over or if he's
just realizing the scope
of we don't know probably more likely
the latter because i can't imagine that
that the mcu would want to close off a
multiverse
story of possibilities anytime soon
next up ant-man and the wasp in quantum
mania
this one we now know for certain is
going to be a multiverse story or at
least
have some implications regarding to it
if only for the presence of
kang the conqueror introduced in the
final episode of loki played by jonathan
magers
that version of kang is dead but we know
kang
shows up in quantum mania which means we
are dealing with a
different version of kang now
will that mean that they actually
acknowledge the version of kang that was
killed in loki
again maybe maybe not i would again be
surprised if it is
required knowledge to understand that
film
but there will be probably be drops and
references and things that make it clear
that like
oh what's going on with this guy however
they choose to make use of kang
in quantomania what's going on with this
guy it goes way
way beyond all the rest of just this
film this is massive implications
that's what i think they'll end up doing
there now the third film
which is a bit more based off of rumor
but these rumors have been
pretty consistent in terms of the kinds
of things they have been pointing to and
it would also tie into some other things
and potentially answer some questions
and that is the third mcu spider-man
movie so that's spider-man
no way home how does a multiverse play
into this well we don't know exactly at
this point because as i said at least at
time of recording
we don't have a trailer yet but there's
a couple of things there has been
leaks and rumors and i i tried to scour
back through and find which of these
were confirmed after a while i gave up
because
so many things that aren't confirmed or
reported as confirmed and trying to
actually break down the sources i
just i didn't have the spoons for this
but there has been word
of the appearances of people
like tobey maguire
andrew garfield alfred molina even
willem defoe
so if all of this pans out to be true
then it it would appear that spider-man
no way home
is also going to be a multiverse story
and they may have felt somewhat
empowered to do that given how effective
into the spider-verse was so i i do kind
of
wonder if they were already planning to
go that direction
with the tom holland spider-man movies
or if they were inspired by just
how successful into the spider-verse was
and i mean
creatively successful it like it made
its money back
at the box office it didn't both things
over but like everyone agrees that thing
was amazing
and it obviously opens up a ton of
possibilities now i mentioned it might
answer some questions that have been
hanging around and that has to do with
venom
and also the upcoming morbius and maybe
eventually down the road even
uh craven the hunter movie if that
actually ever ends up happening
because there have been small things at
play in that we've seen
in trailers for the next venom movie and
for
morbius whenever the heck those end up
coming out
that tie them into spider-man but not
the mcu spider-man
there was a poster image like in an
alley of spider-man but it wasn't tom
holland spider-man
a character seen reading the daily bugle
but in the mcu continuity the daily
bugle is
a web series it's an infowars style
thing
online and that daily bugle newspaper
that look like that came from the tobey
maguire there is the possibility
of now tying in these extra things that
sony has been doing into the mcu
indirectly this would actually kind of
be an
everybody one scenario sort of thing
because sony would like
basically the association and the kind
of stamp of approval for these
characters that they have
because marvel doesn't want them what
doesn't want what sony's doing with them
in the main mcu
to sony wants them to be more associated
it's more lucrative that way
this is a bit of a havoc have your cake
you need it too because if you make them
part of the multiverse
that does make them part of the mcu
but not in a way unless you actually
find some way to integrate them into the
primary continuity
they're now you know they're canon but
not in a way that kevin feige and the
folks at the mcu actually have to
actively deal with or manage
in any way they can be like yeah i mean
it's part of the multiverse
all right i'm i said i was going to come
back to wanda so let me circle back on
that
so at the end of wanda vision in the
post-credit sequence we saw wanda
messing around with the dark hold
i still hate that but it is what it is i
need to deal with it
so we heard the voices
of her sons billy and tommy
who in the main mcu are established to
be
fabrications of her she made them up
she invented this life with vision a
vision she created so
vision did die but she
is still clutching to the idea that she
can have her family
that she can save them and possibly a
driving motivator for her especially if
she's an
antagonistic force in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
is that she is trying to find a reality
where her boys are alive
to try and reunite with them and
depending on how they do that that has a
lot of possibilities
certainly for emotional weight um
for a lot of serious ethical questions
especially
if like she tries to pull them from a
reality where these kids have their own
wanda who is their mother and you get
like a little bit into sort of the
the weird tunnel vision villain nature
of say
kingpin in into the spider-verse it
really is a good
uh touchstone to go to for as this stuff
starts to play out
i am still a little bit nervous if they
go that direction with wanda because it
also has the potential to
do the whole
grief and trauma broke someone and made
them a villain narrative which
i i'm not going to say it never ever
works for
hero turned villain but i
almost never like it so i'm kind of
hoping not but
i i would be shocked if those two
characters don't factor in
some way especially because um
billy uh who in the comics is the
character wiccan
is kind of a fan favorite and
in particular he's one of the more
prominent queer
characters in the marvel comics so
there's definitely going to be calls
from
folks from a similar background or a
living situation as me
in terms of their own gender identity or
belief in the importance of lgbtq plus
representation who are going to want
some way
to bring that character in another thing
to wonder about
is whether or not this will factor into
the eternals at all
now there isn't necessarily a reason to
think that it has to
for the things that we have started to
learn about what appears to be the story
in quantum mania multiverse of madness
and
no way home the multiverse is absolutely
going to be
present now with the eternals and the
premise well the premise of the
characters in general and what the film
with the
initial trailer appears to be going for
this sort of uh ancient aliens
thing you know coming back to earth to
be protectors or guides or what have you
does not require a multiverse story in
order to work
however if you wanted to bring the
multiverse into play
it could be used to answer one main
question
about the core concept of that
film and those characters which is
throughout the years we have never
interfered
until now
why are you just showing up now and you
did absolutely nothing during the events
of
infinity war you didn't think
that was worth showing up and like that
is a question worth and
worth answering and it's not one unique
to marvel this was
kind of an issue that uh dc ran into
with wonder woman when
initially official canon was after
her uh first adventure out in world war
one
wonder woman basically just mourned
steve trevor
for a century and they've tried to uh
fill in the holes in that a little bit
since
not with too much success but like those
kinds of things do
cause problems and so when you have
something like the eternals where the
concept seems to be
we've come here because we were needed
the immediate question is you were
needed before where were you
well a multiverse if they come from a
different reality or were stuck in a
different reality
or anything along those lines could
answer the question of
why we hadn't seen them up to this point
and on a similar note it's been well
speculated by more than a few people
that
that same premise of this would explain
why we haven't seen
x thing up until now could be used to
explain a number of things now
i wouldn't go overboard with this
there's a plenty of things that you
could
do it with i think there's really only a
couple of things where
it might be more efficient to do it this
way
the first of those being the x-men
because
with prejudice and fear of these people
and having that be analogous to many
real world oppressed groups be it um you
know oppressed races
uh oppressed minorities people who are
oppressed for their disabilities and
lgbtq plus people etc
it kind of damages the
metaphor at play and the applicability
if we get to the point where the x-men
are going to be integrated into the mcu
and suddenly it's just a case of
mutants the they've just started
happening mutant genes are activated all
over the place we don't know what's
going on like you'd still
have the fact that these people aren't
responsible for
uh you know the fact that they are
mutants and it's still
you know they're being oppressed for
something that's not their fault that
would still be in play but it would
kind of diminish the idea of this is an
ongoing possibly even systemic
prejudicial issue against mutants if
they all just start showing up at the
same time
so a possible way around that is to
by some means and there's a lot of
different ways to do it
but by some means have the
introduction of mutants be through a
multiverse that they
originated in some other reality that
two realities merge
possibly due to events from any of the
films i've mentioned up to this point
and that some other place where mutants
have been an ongoing
problem and it could be a way of
getting mutants involved in the main
continuity
without having to explain why mutants
haven't come up as a thing up to this
point
now if they wanted to go a step further
with it they could
actually connect this to the existing
fox x-men continuity i would be
shocked if they did that though not
for the reason you might be thinking the
snarky reason was it sucks
fox basically ran the thing into the
ground why would they want to
i'm not going to go that direction but i
will say that
the main draws of the fox x-men movies
aren't going to want to dedicate
themselves to
another 10 movie contracts like because
who were the big
big names the big ones
were hugh jackman as wolverine and
patrick stewart as professor x and they
both signed off those parts
i'm not saying you could never uh like
give them enough money to have them come
back save maybe once
but fans wouldn't want them back once
they would want them back
as these characters so i think
just because they would not be able to
bring back
all of the major players or you know ian
mcallen as magneto for that matter
look all respect to james mcavoy michael
fassbender
they're not as iconic they're i'm sorry
they're not
so the inability or at least
my perceiving of there being an
inability to bring those people back and
commit them
to future projects kind of makes that an
unappealing option
now i wouldn't be surprised if at some
point in some
manner that universe of x-men films gets
acknowledged as being part of the
multiverse
especially if we get like a really big
multiversal story which
might be multiverse of madness or might
be something else depending on how long
they plan to keep kang around
i would not be surprised if somewhere
along the line they in
some way confirm that that
world is part of the multiverse think of
it a bit like okay i don't know if you
saw
the cw crossover their version on crisis
on infinite earth you don't have to
watch the whole thing
but my point being is that at the front
end they had a
ton of short clips using single
actors from you know completely
different continuities and
interpretations of these characters
just to show that that universe was part
of the multiverse
so they use robert wool playing the
reporter character that he played in the
original 1989 batman to confirm
that the tim burton batman movies are
part of this multiverse they had bert
ward
you know the robin from the 1960s
version
of batman with adam west he made a brief
appearance again confirming that that's
somewhere in the multiverse now
these realities never came into play
they were basically acknowledged and
then well
actually destroyed but but you know you
didn't have to dwell on them but they
did get acknowledged so i wouldn't be
surprised if something like that
gets done with the fox x-men movies and
potentially also the
fox fantastic four any version of it
because i can't imagine they are going
to pull that in and want to actively
work
with any of that now some people have
floated the idea that the multiverse
might still be used to
talk about or bring up the fantastic
four partially just because
the main appeal of the fantastic four
especially at
this point in time is that they are a
bit old-fashioned
in the comics they are kind of the old
guard they're the ones who have been
around
um the longest the idea of them
showing up for the first time you know
as an origin story
this late into a marvel continuity just
strikes a lot of people as odd and kind
of antithetical to the characters
i don't think that's necessarily true
and i do think there are
ways that they could still just
introduce the fantastic four i don't
think it's
necessary to pull them in from an
alternate reality
that said another part of the temptation
to do it
that way especially if we get some sort
of weird
overlapping of several realities into a
new
merged main universe which is like i
said the kind of thing that could be
used to explain mutants
that i think more important than the
fantastic before
that might be a viable option for
introducing dr
doom because again
depending on how kevin feige and marvel
ultimately want
to bring in the fantastic four a bit
like the question i asked about the
eternals
it's kind of a question of why haven't
we heard from
doom because victor von doom
while he certainly when he's in scheming
mode
can be very isolationist and just
sitting in his castle in latvia
he also really kind of has his pulse on
stuff that's going on that's kind of his
deal
he's always looking for things to
manipulate things to take advantage of
he's
watching for his moment now that's not
to say you can't
say he's been continuing to wait and
only now has his moment come
but like you are gonna kind of have to
acknowledge why nothing
prior to this was his moment why wasn't
you know the chaos caused by
hydra that why wasn't that his moment
why wasn't the aftermath of you know
what happened in new york his moment the
sokovia accords that sort of crippled
the
ability of the avengers to do anything
why wasn't that his moment
so if the marvel folks decided they
didn't
want to deal with any of those questions
well you could pull in a doom or even
latveria entirely as a country
in from a alternate universe and do it
that way again
i don't think it's necessary this kind
of illustrates one of the things that i
don't like about
multiverses and having it available or
at least what makes me nervous about it
it's very easy to turn to and go oh
we'll just pull that in from the
multiverse
and if you overdo that it becomes
a very boring default answer for
basically
any continuity hiccup ah yeah well
whenever you notice something like that
a wizard did it i see all right yes but
in episode ag4 wizard
it's this catch-all answer it's this
all-purpose spackle for continuity
errors
and i'm not gonna say it doesn't work
for that but if you overuse it for that
then
suddenly the universe as a whole becomes
a lot less interesting to think about
what might happen because instead of
and like look i'm not even that into
doing fan theory but instead of getting
involved in the massive elaborate fan
theories and speculation that people
like to do and is a big part of the
engagement of this fandom
if they overdo this people are just
going to start trying going
it'll be because the multiverse you know
they'll hear about an announced
film or character or whatever and
instead of being like oh how will they
introduce that how would that be brought
in
people just start going it'll be the
multiverse it's just less engaging
now will that happen i don't know i hope
not but i'm going to be nervous about it
so a couple of other things so i
mentioned the x-men and i would be
a bit remiss not to bring up deadpool
now i've actually made the argument in
the past that you could connect
deadpool to the mcu um although
having him up here and like an avengers
would be tricky but having him
openly acknowledge or even having mcu
characters appear with him in his own
movies isn't difficult at all he's such
a fourth wall breaking character
he kind of plays by his own rules in the
first place
and again you could use a multiverse to
bring him in but i think it's more
fun by his fourth wall breaking nature
like to just have him just mess with
things
again i think largely in his own movies
which i expect will continue to be the
case because unless disney
uh nerfs him into a pg-13 if they keep
him in our rating which they've
said they intend to do then
integrating him directly into the mcu
as a you know appearing there as opposed
to like bits of that appearing where he
is it's yeah i'm not so sure about that
i mean keep in mind
fear of an r rating was a big part of
the dispute uh
with marvel over whether or not they
were going to be okay with the venom
movie
being acknowledged as being in the mcu
uh back when it looked like that might
be r-rated
so with deadpool here's i think there's
a middle ground with him
what you could do if you need to again i
would argue you don't even need to do
this
but if you desperately needed to and
couldn't stop yourself
you could say that his entire fourth
wall breaking shtick
is either a result of
or um feeds into
[Music]
a uh awareness of the multiverse
that for whatever reason he just knows
he just knows all these different
realities are going on and he has some
kind of awareness of them
and that's part of the deal if you
wanted to give
internal context for all of his fourth
wall breaks
so one other thing i want to touch on
which is something i'm afraid of
dead characters coming back because yeah
tony stark's dead but
hey look at this we found a different
universe where he's still alive and now
he's back and like look
here's the thing i have just enough
faith
don't disappoint me on this marvel but
i've just enough faith that marvel
won't do that partly
because well a big chunk of the reason
why these characters
were retired was because the actors were
done with their contracts and they
wanted to move on
some actors have stayed past their
contracts chris hemsworth has
samuel jackson has but chris evans
robert downey jr
no they were they were good they were
done that's part of why those characters
were closed out when they were
so i don't think that marvel is
actually going to do that
tell you what i'm not looking forward to
though all of the fans will keep saying
they should do it
and like this is not
really going to be marvel's fault
but that is a big part of what i have
not looked forward to in terms of the
entire concept of having a multiverse
i am not looking forward to all of the
things that
fans are gonna start saying they should
be doing
because the multiverse means that it's
theoretically possible
that is one of the downsides of
introducing some you know when you have
a big expansive franchise with a very
dedicated and involved
and engaged fan base when you introduce
something that allows you to do almost
anything
then some fans
not all probably not even a majority but
some fans
are going to get very loud about
demanding to know why you aren't
doing certain things since the
logistical hurdles of why you couldn't
at least narrative logistical hurdles
have been removed
why is tony stark still dead when you
could pull another one from the
multiverse again there are logistical
answers to that
but that's not going to satisfy rabid
fans
you remove the narrative hurdle so why
aren't you doing it
and maybe it won't be as bad as i think
maybe even if it is it'll be short-lived
but like
that's the kind of
nonsense that goes on in
comic book fandom spaces that is part of
the reason i'm not
really an active part of those fan
spaces
so in terms of fan culture it does worry
me that we're inviting
some of the stuff that i was glad was
staying
with just the comic book fandom and
inviting that
into the film fandom which
ah look marvel actually i think for the
most part
has fairly decent fans like are there
bad elements yeah
they exist in every single freaking
fandom but in terms of the fandoms that
i have
some degree of involvement in these days
so you know this
star wars still a little bit doctor who
marvel
seems the most chilled out uh out of
those in dc
like i know people think i hate dc i do
actually like it i'm just
they do more things that tick me off i'm
sorry
but marvel seems like one of the more
chilled out fandoms and i
i worry about losing that
but that's me and that's my hang up
although somewhat tied to the
um dead characters or alternate versions
of the same character
thing is i will be curious to see if
they
choose to use the multiverse as a reason
to actually canonize
the upcoming what if animated series
that's coming to disney plus which i
think is the next series due to release
because those were being positioned as
just
well here's something that could have
happened it isn't but it's a thought
it's like a thought exercise
for the most part are they now actually
going to position those
as different universes as being part of
the actual multiverse
because they could and it wouldn't
affect the actual stories themselves
that are being told in any given episode
of what if
it really would just come to come down
to whether or not they have uatu the
watcher
lay that out as part of like an intro or
outro to the dang thing
that would be enough to establish that
i kind of hope they don't because i
think at this point fans are going to
presume that it's part of the multiverse
anyway
and confirming it again this is more to
do with my own
hang-ups knowing some of the stuff that
they're doing but it's gonna
i fear that it's going to again
encourage fans to demand oh but this
what if that thing was so cool we should
have it in the main universe
and of course the big one i worry about
is marvel zombies
because i hate marvel zombies i know
some people like it
that's great i hate it i really hate it
i'm i'm kind of glad that it looks like
it's getting burned off
uh as a concept in the what if animated
let it stay there so the one other thing
that i'll be curious to see how it pans
out
is the use of kang the conqueror
beyond his appearance in ant-man because
it always struck me as odd the idea of
having kang
in ant-man given the kind of villain
that he is again like i mentioned this
in my loki review
i don't think kang's very interesting
the comic version of kang i actually
really really really
liked jonathan major's take on him and
what we got from that character i
actually
really really dig and i'm kind of
excited to see him again
but kang's kind of a big fish
to be putting into a ant-man
film you know especially given the
light-hearted nature
of those films he's an odd pick for a
more comedically leaning franchise
but given that part of the whole
thing done with loki is the idea of
we're not dealing with one kang we are
dealing with
a multitude of them and they're not all
going to operate in the exact same way
i would be very curious to see how that
plays out
going forward because rather than having
one character
who you try and fit into all these other
stories what you technically have
is a bunch of completely different
versions of that same character
so you can tailor one to fit into a
slightly more comedic bend
in quantomania you can tailor one to be
more threatening more outright
dangerous in a future avengers
and i will be curious to see how they
balance this because again
much like the multiverse itself it would
be possible to overuse kang if they just
start sticking him in everything
because they can it's going to get old
real quick
but it could be a very interesting way
to build up an eventual
big you know biggest threat version of
kang
however they want to do that by by
introducing us to all these other ones
so we've had the one in loki
uh he who remains which may or may not
have been the immortus
version i've seen some people say it is
i'm not convinced of that but it could
be
but you have that and
like i'm not saying you have to pull the
actual some of the variants of kang
like uh like ramat or anything like
that's not what i mean like just have
him be kang
and have him but have him be different
and you could have some version of him
show up
in various things where like oh boy that
that
was kind of a problem but hinting at i
don't know this isn't the worst version
this isn't the worst version until we
get that worst version
and have that be the next big avengers
thanos style threat and they actually
don't really have to do that because the
thing is
kang became the mechanism to open up the
multiverse they don't actually have to
keep using it
now that the multiverse is open you can
introduce a ton a variety of threats
galactus would be another one
that you could easily now bring in not
that you would have needed the
multiverse to do that
necessarily but again if you wanted to
pull over fantastic four from a
different universe you could have
whatever they were doing to try and
defeat galactus actually end up
throwing the fantastic four and galactus
into the main marvel universe and now
suddenly
the avengers have to deal with galactus
a threat they've never encountered
before and don't know what to do with
potentially but if they stick with kang
if they build up to like a
most dangerous version of kang i do
think that would be a really
interesting way to have someone a threat
on this
that feels like it's on the scale of
thanos without feeling like a repeat
because i've honestly kind of wondered
where do you go after thanos like when
you've killed half of the
flipping universe and then managed to
undo that and you've dealt with the
threat that did that
how do you introduce anything else
because almost anything else you
introduce
is gonna feel like less of a threat or
if you try and one-up it
it's gonna devalue the me what thanos
meant at the time
it's always a risky play when you go
that big to then keep continuing the
story with these characters and
you know introducing new villains now
again the villains in the individual
franchises
not a concern but pulling together for
an avengers film
kang would be an interesting way to do
it because the
way of him operating all these different
versions
means that the way he can be built up is
completely
different from the way thanos was built
up he doesn't have to be
background ominous plotting
you know off in his space chair he could
be active on the ground he could get
defeated he could even get killed
but we're still gonna deal with him
again later
there's pitfalls as i said you could
overdo it um
but i think that that is a really good
way
to give him just a different feel
it's not just oh he's big and powerful
and has the most powerful
skills which is basically what thanos
had once he had the infinity gauntlet
no this guy's got a unique
set of skills a unique threat that isn't
necessarily more
powerful than thanos if like you were to
stat them
out but it's a very different
kind of threat that is still a big big
problem so for all the stuff going on
with the multiverse all the stuff that
is going to happen all the stuff that
might happen all the stuff that
fans are gonna say should happen even
though it's probably not a good idea
the thing that excites me most is what
happens with kang
how long are they going to keep him
around how are they going to use him
because i think there's some of the most
interesting possibilities
in that villain and again jonathan b
just
flip and nailed it and i want more
those are my rambling thoughts on the
multiverse
the fact that it exists where we're
going to see it how it might be used and
then
looking forward to future possibilities
of how else it might be used down the
line
what are your thoughts on it on any of
this whatever they are drop something
down in the comments
let's talk about it i have a patreon
that is how i pay my bills and i'm able
to keep this
and i'm able to keep this entire
operation up and running so i would
encourage you to check that out
or you can also do youtube memberships
support me that way
but no pressure
the usual the usual stuff of like share
and subscribe
all helps me out and besides
i'm not going to tell you what to do
because at the end of the day
you're the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
now
[Music]